okay
yeah let's play something else
the old london oh he goes bishop five
that's it that's interesting
i'm sure he has good prep here i'm just
curious
generally you take him b1 here
just curious to see what he's gonna do
so the whole point of taking b1 is that
you
prevent your opponent from castling
which is obviously a
pretty nice achievement
people are night now they're good night
t5 here
i guess not
whatever i don't know what to do doing
here so i'll play by few
so he's gonna win uh he's gonna win the
piece back clearly
but my hope is that
i will have some structural advantage
and that my king can eventually
escape from the center
and frankly at the moment my king
doesn't look very threatened
now i talked to him and he's not
threatened so what can i say
so my intention is if
let's say knight d5 or something
then my intention was basically
to yeah just to go bishop g2 let him
take on f4
with whatever piece go brooks t1 pick up
the pawn and just
claim to have some structural advantage
and i don't see any reason why
that wouldn't be true now as well
although
this maneuver rook to b6 does bother me
a bit
he's quite good at finding these
defensive resources
okay i don't have anything else i'll
have to take
oregon's 95 immediately
maybe that's even better
you are just nothing
it would be quite an unfortunate
development
okay let me try which before protecting
the rook and
on um on b1 and clearly i i want
him to capture on f4 because i don't
want
to take on d6 and improve his spawn
structure
i think he will go rook b6 okay
h4 h6 i go h4
he wanted g5 to force my uh my bishop to
to make a decision there
it's really not easy to find a good way
to
to defend against rook b8 because what i
would love to do is king d2
to c2 but then um
then he would go with um
[Music]
he would say take on a3 and
that thing is not actually protected
okay let me let me just for a second
make sure
that i don't blunder king c1 is rook b2
possible
root b2
uh bishop a3 rook c2 knight c3
let me see their especially takes c6
though
yeah okay doesn't work for him
i'm still not sure what to do next
maybe you can go rook b3 and if i go
bishop c2 which is the logical response
um then
yeah then he would probably just
take a b2 rugby to bishop a3 and i don't
have a rook c2 anymore
yeah rick p3 is good maybe i broke
a4 though there's knight b6 followed by
knight c4
okay not condensed
if now of course rook
um rook 8 to b5 would be a huge mistake
because of bishop c2
tracking the rook so he does have some
questions to answer here
but i believe there should be some
solution for him
but probably rook f4 was underestimated
or missed by him
and he's spending a lot of time clearly
doesn't know what to do
just good i don't see what he should do
either
okay he goes back bishop d3
okay this is pretty clever bishop c4
there's a rook c3 check
and then there's then you can take an a3
so what if i take a d6 first
and what i'll do is i'll go bishop c2
and then i'll take on d6 and then bishop
d3
that seems seems to be good i think i'm
winning a5
b3 now
oh damn it he's still okay i can just
take on d5 first
sure
he does have some kind of play though i
think i'll just have to go for it
cd5 then he doubles his rocks
but i don't think it's it's quite
sufficient
go b4 okay tries to run
okay i'm short time
seriously sure time i think this should
be very good
roxy 7 now and then i push
okay yeah this is not a perpetual
rookie two okay two
let's just make sure i don't blend or
anything
protect against mate and he lost some
time
okay that was uh a bit
nervy at the end but i think overall
uh i calculated things
decently well at least better than
than he he did